Okay,
philosophical question,
what is the definition of shadows and because Ron along,
so it was all people already,
even for an hour,
uh,
us,
let's for now,
but only for now.
They can.
Shadows are niches that are not visible from light sources.
And again,
if you're a how transport or if you're bored with an extra such as this one,
but hopefully not this one and well you can take a look at the chateau and
regions and you will,
you will immediately recognize that these are the regions that are somehow
included,
which respect to the light source.
Let's take a look at an example.
This small red dot on the top.
This is
a light source.
This is a point of light source and this black thing is a sphere.
And behind that,
what would respect to the light source?
We have an umbrella.
This is a completely shadowed region.
This is the name of the completely shadowed region.
And if we are able to shape these points in the ray tracer,
and if I want shadows,
then I need to compute whether this way when I'm shading the point is obstructed
or occluded from the light source or not.
But this is very simple to do.
So imagine that.
I would like to shake this point below on the plane and what I will do is I
would sand or a that I call a shadow rate towards the light source was
interested in is is it obstruct?
Obstructed means that it hits something before it's blocked by something.
So the first question is,
is an incredibly difficult question.
Is this whole structured or not?
It is indeed.
Okay,
what about this guy?
This is obstructed as well.
Okay.
What about these guys?
These guys are good.
Okay,
cool.
So it is for now the very simple concept shadows.
It means that I also have a visibility signal that I wanted by the intensity
with,
and this is finally,
obviously the rain either hits an object or it doesn't.
That's it.
Very simple.
This intensity that is not radiums,
but this is the hack that we use in ray tracing.
This is the simpler version of things.
Still,
I'm going to set to Ciro,
whatever showed you.
They have at that point,
I don't care.
It is in shadows.
It's going to be completely black.
So this is the simple version.
What about real life?
Well,
in real life,
probably cloud services don't exist because the point by mathematical definition
is off measures zero.
It means that it's infinitely small and something that is infinitely small.
Well,
we call it a light source so that this is something that has infinite is,
but it has given amount of energy.
Why don't you go ask Stephen Hawking?
He would say that this is the definition of a black hole.
So we were terrible at court and if this would happen,
we would have much bigger problems than computing shadow raise.
So that's definitely out of our interest at the moment.
So we haven't had a light source and we still have the ombre because none of the
rays make it to the light source.
But we have a different region that we call [inaudible],
which are partially shadowed regions.
So thanks.
I wrote to that much more interesting.
Now I'm going to shoot to shadow raise from the surface towards different
regions of the loud source.
What about these guys?
What about the right shadow rate?
Good.
Okay.
What about the left?
Good.
It's not a pollutant.
Okay,
excellent.
So this is this.
Some already doesn't seem binary anymore and this visibility signal,
it's going to be continuous.
So there may be points which are visible from some part of the light source but
not visible from an added part of the light source.
And therefore we have some kind of partial occlusion.
And the question is how do we compute this?
How can we write a program that can give me a beautiful Allin Bra and not just
hard shadows.
So if we only have the umbrella,
this is in the literature,
this is called hard shadows and Penumbra is soft shadows.
We're going to see examples of that in a second.
So very simple.
Let's try to approximate the era after the light source that is visible from
that point.
Whoever the whole area off the light source.
Let's see an example of that.
But first I'm interested in how to approximate this because I'm talking more
areas and this sounds like some kind of integration problem and for now we are
not going to retaliate in the gloss over it.
Yes.
For instance,
what we can do is we could shoot a lot of shadow raced and tried to approximate
this area.
So the approximation is going to be the following.
I'm interested in the physical shadow raced a number of visible shadow race over
all the shadow race that I have computed.
Well example,
how was this region going to look like?
Well,
I'm going to shoot 100 shadow raise from this small black dots and I'm
interested in how many of them is going to make it to the light source.
What do you think?
Well,
uh,
out of 100 chatter race,
does 100 heat the line source?
Definitely not.
Well last 50
probably not.
Okay,
well it's actually,
it's quite reasonably dark there.
So let's say that three of them is the line source.
It's very simple approximation.
I should 100 shadow raise three of them and therefore this is what I'm going to
multiply this intensity that I have computed with.
Okay.
What about the next major?
This is a bit far,
far away.
Out of 100 does 100 of people hit this region?
Definitely not half of them but do you think first time definitely.
Okay,
cool.
And if we go even more out of the Ombre then I have this white dog and I'm
interested in how many of these could hit the light source.
I think that that can be,
there are regions where we should meet are definitely all started but it's not
too much.
So let's say that 95% of the shadow is hit the light source so I can let me
compute in a way self chatters,
not only shadows but now soft shadows.
You're going to see examples of that and what we have done here is actually
Monte-carlo integration and you're going to hear a lot about Monte Carlo
integration.
It's in every list.
I don't know,
some teenage people look up the top 10 builder list of the best music clips off
lady Gaga and the others.
What I do myself,
I can test.
I do have the top 10 mathematical techniques nowadays.
And I tell you that Monte Carlo integration is always on the beer board topless.
It's one of the most effective techniques to evaluate integrals.
And we're going to study them extensively and it's going to make your life
infinitely simpler.
Not a quick question.
Yes.
Can such an image for you physically correct.
But obviously it's a drawing so it's not correct.
But those something that unbelievably so incorrect that it would,
it would need some attention.
Who can tell me that?
Yes.
Okay.
That is true.
Unfortunately this is a mind reading exercise.
So you would have to figure out what I have thought.
Just getting that's absolutely true.
But that people pick yes.
Pissed down.
Well,
um,
as far as I know,
physics delight should spend a little bit in roads from the object,
but that's not the,
the,
we are very far away from that.
[inaudible] you are absolutely true.
So if I say in terms of shadows,
wait,
I would've said something funny about the shadows from the air shuttles.
Indeed.
Where
between the object and the ground like yes.
Okay.
What's what's up with you?
Should
error wouldn't technically be shadow themselves.
Which Arrow?
The area of art.
The air part between the old chicken
but it's
at this [inaudible] between the surface of the object is empty space,
which is,
what about if I ask about this transition from here to the outside.
So if you imagine this boss that we have,
if I will put it in the Umbra and I will slowly move out of there.
Would I experience such a jump that I see here?
Okay,
why not?
Because if I start from the Ombre,
it may be that yes,
I cannot construct any kind of rate that he's the light source and as I move
outwards it will continuously increase this probability.
There is not going to be a jump that you see this abrupt Connor change.
It is going to be a perfectly smooth gradient,
almost perfectly smooth gradient depending on many other physical properties.
But this is more or less what I would say.
And there's going to be an example of that in a second.
So this is what I have said for those who are reading this at home.
And the question is very simple question,
what kind of lights are still we have on this image?
It's a part of dried source.
Excellent.
Why?
Right?
Because I don't see it.
I see.
Excellent.
So this should be a point like source and what technically you could say that if
you have a smaller airline source but only one shadow race.
So you don't do this integration just on one channel,
you can have something similar for this.
But uh,
generally these are 0.5 sources.
What about these guys
forms?
The left one seems to be a point.
I source the right one.
I can see this beautiful continuous change and this is definitely a felony.
But if I take a look at this region below this object that I can also see some
kind of new bro.
So it might be that it,
this is a small on the left.
It's a small area,
light source that is close to the object perhaps.
And this is why I don't see the blueprint,
but other places I see it and here on the right it has a really pronounced
effect.
So is definitely an area light source.
Okay,
well the next question is that in physical reality we usually don't see
perfectly black shadows.
So if I take a look around in this room I see shadows,
I see their region that is in this and then some kind of raw and the Lube Raj
something.
But this is anything about perfectly,
yes that's true.
So there is an effect that we are going to talk about next lecture and it is
called indirect illumination
and this basically we use that.
Okay.
In a in Vra tracing program we are only accounting for the direct effect of an
outsource.
But in physical reality it is possible that did the light comes in through this
window.
He's no more.
First is wide wall and then he's the grounds in this or Asian and then it goes
to words Maya and therefore some of the energy is going to be big type.
So the effect of this white wall is going to make these black or dark channels
lighter.
Yeah.
And this we cannot compute yet.
This is multiple diffuse balances after each other.
We cannot take this into account.
We would need to solve the full rendering equation for this.
So what we have is direct illumination and this is why the MBM term comes into
place.
What we have been talking about this ambulance term is just basically adding
something to this intensity that I have.
Why?
Because this was the image of it.
So I would have perfectly black shadows and for instance,
for this classroom I would have an ambient intensity that is a collar that has
greatly and therefore these regions will not be perfectly black,
but I would add the sticks,
great numbers and therefore it would be a bit more grip.
So this is a happy,
this is a really crude approximation of indirect elimination,
but it more or less works.
At least it is an accepted way to cheat back this last energy in a ray tracer.
Yes.
For the,
um,
multicultural techniques casita shed the race.
Uh,
how we,
how do we determine where at the surface of the night where you're shooting the
points because there's a surface or do we pick some random points on the
surface?
These are difficult details of ray tracing programs.
There are techniques that help you to pick a uniformly,
uh,
chosen random direction on a sphere for instance,
that I would shoot or uniform directions or points.
So I choose a random point on a,
and I'm going to connect this to that other point.
And so perfectly uniformly chosen random points.
This I need to generate on the surface of the light source and this I would need
to sample.
And there's also organizations for that because what if a life force has a
nonuniform radiation?
So some light sources are be times in one direction but not in others.
How do I account for that?
And there's even optimization techniques for that.
And then the short beauty break,
while
we like plugs around there a lot and,
but they see us that apparently some nerds are living their dreams in our
program and creating people like that.
There is lots of programs that help you achieving these realistic things.
And,
and later on we will talk a bit about how skin realistic skin can be achieved,
such as the one that you can see here.
It kind of skin is not a surface.
Skin is a volume.
So not everyone knows,
but some amount of the light is penetrating the surface of the skin and it goes
beneath.
It gets scared and absorbed maybe even a thousand times there.
And it may come out somebody else from your skin.
And this is why the,
there are computer games in the older computer games.
This is why humans look really fake and plastic because they don't account for
this effect.
And the nurse computer games can compute this or something like this in real
time.
And this is what makes them so beautiful.